what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have a deleted alternate
post-credits scene that would have been
in black widow if they had decided to go
this route and depending on your views
you could actually think that this would
have been a better post credit scene for
natasha i actually think that they could
have thrown this in with the other
post-credits scene with mason and not
had to choose between the two of them
they could have done this one first and
the one with mason and the quinjet after
but i'll let you decide for yourself
i'll show some clips and the stills so
it doesn't get copyrighted but i'll show
it nonetheless then of course after i'll
break it down and we'll talk about what
exactly this scene would have meant if
it was kept in the movie and we also do
have some rumors flying around about
scarlett johansson and disney there have
been some rumors going around talking
about how scarlett won't ever be in
another mcu project again i'll break
that down after this and of course if
you love marvel and want to stay up to
date on everything that's happening be
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos okay so it's
about a minute long and we start off by
seeing a motorcycle come down a street
in a neighborhood we then see some kids
run outside of a house and we see the
motorcycle ride even more down into the
neighborhood as we see the kids in the
neighborhood play a little bit more we
can actually see that they're acting and
playing like they're the avengers we see
two little girls run by one of them
seems to have some type of wings on her
back she could be acting like she's
falcon the girl behind her has black
bands on her arms acting like she's
natasha then a boy runs by that has the
same black bands on as well acting like
he is natasha we then see a kid with a
bow obviously pretending like he's
hawkeye and we also see a kid jumping on
a trampoline with a small captain
america shield kinda like a one for
toddlers that you would just go to
target and pick up so as these kids are
playing avengers natasha comes around
the corner stops her bike gets off and
takes her helmet off she looks up and
the house that she grew up in as a child
for those few years with her so-called
family with yelena bulova molina
vostakov and alexis shostakov aka the
red guardian and we can see that it's a
rather emotional scene for her as she is
staring at the house reminiscing of her
past clearly very emotional some of the
kids that were playing avengers walk by
her the kid with the captain america
shield runs right by her however the
little girl who was playing like she was
black widow recognizes her she walks up
slowly behind her checking to see if it
really is her natasha smiles at her then
the little girl realizing that it's her
holds up her arm with her pretend black
widow bracelet and gives her a little
black widow bite natasha holds up her
arm and pretends to do the same back to
her and that's the scene now keep in
mind this is not an alternate post
credit scene this is an alternate ending
which i assume will be released when the
movie actually comes out on dvd and
blu-ray or wherever you want to buy it
i'm sure it's going to come out with the
film but this would have replaced the
scene with mason where she rides up on
her bike and she gets the quinjet and
that scene really has more connections
to infinity war because we know that
after she gets in the quinjet she goes
and breaks some of her fellow heroes out
of the raft so i can definitely see why
they went with that scene instead of
this scene it connects a lot more to the
events that were about to happen in
infinity war however although in the
mcu's timeline infinity war had not
taken place yet in real life it had and
i think a lot of people realize what
natasha would go on to do she would go
on to fight in infinity war and then
avengers in-game and then ultimately die
and since we ourselves and a good
majority of the people know that i think
this alternate ending is a little bit
more emotional and i think it kind of
ties you into natasha just a little bit
more you feel for her one last time and
i think it really just depends on what
you would want to feel at the end of the
movie would you want to feel a more
emotional connection to natasha a kind
of happy emotional scene right here
where we see that she's inspired little
girls and little boys as a hero and not
as a russian assassin or would you have
wanted what we actually got a setup for
what happens in avengers in-game for
what we actually knew was going to
happen and i actually think that they
probably could have done both they could
have shown this scene and then shown the
other scene with mason now clearly the
movie was super long and they needed to
cut some parts but i feel like if you
took a little bit out of this scene and
then took a little bit from the scene
with mason and the quinjet you probably
could have put them both together
because think about this and this is
actually why i prefer this scene over
the quinjet scene this would have been
the last time that we saw black widow
the last time ever seen natasha on
screen if you take away all of the
different multiversal aspects of it the
variant aspects of it yes perhaps we
could see a variant of her one day or
maybe not depending on the recent
reports which i'll talk about at the end
but if you put all of that aside this
would be the last time that we actually
get to see natasha in the mcu on screen
and for that sole reason is why i
actually prefer this deleted alternate
ending why because it actually shows
natasha in a very good light because the
black widow movie is all about her this
is her film it's about her tackling her
past it's about her coming face to face
with dracob again about her coming face
to face with antonia drakov's daughter
who they had been teasing us since the
very first avengers film the whole story
is that she was an assassin before she
killed a lot of people but ultimately
she turned good and did what she had to
do to go down the right path and in the
movie they actually kind of talk about
this yolina and natasha natasha says i
was trying to do something good be more
than just a trained killer and yelena
says you're fooling yourself we are
still both trained killers i'm not the
killer that little girls call their hero
this is a direct reference to that line
that yelena drops that exact
conversation where natasha is clearly
stating that she wants to be more than
what she had been she wants to be a hero
and what this scene does is actually
solidify the fact that she is indeed a
hero and she's a hero not only to us but
to the actual people inside the mcu she
made a real impact little girls and
little boys are pretending to be her
because they look up to her and that's
why i personally really like this scene
better than the one that we got not that
i didn't really like it i just would
have preferred this one i think it means
a lot more to the actual character
because we already knew that she was
gonna go break people out of the raft
and go start the events that happened
right before infinity war and then jump
into infinity war and end game but let
me know which one you would prefer in
the comments down below and like i
mentioned there has been some news about
the scarlett johansson lawsuit against
disney according to some reports online
disney has banned scarlett johansson
cameos in any further mcu movies not
like that would ultimately matter
because again we know she's dead but if
this is true this kind of eliminates any
possibility for her popping up as a
different variant of herself down the
road now a lot of people have asked me
about this and i have looked for sources
online and some of these news articles
don't quote any sources so i will throw
a disclaimer out there that this might
not be true at least disney hasn't
publicly stated it yet however i would
not be surprised if it is true because
this whole lawsuit definitely has to be
a strain on the relationship between
scarlett johansson and disney and it
seems like people are truly divided on
it from what we've heard kevin feige is
pretty mad about the whole entire thing
disney of course isn't happy either and
of course scarlett isn't happy again we
don't really know what's going on behind
the scenes but hopefully they figure
something out soon and everything gets
resolved because it would be pretty cool
to see scarlett johansson revise her
role as natasha romanov aka black widow
of course down the road playing a
variant of herself in secret wars
perhaps i personally think we're gonna
see a lot of different variants down the
road and hers is one that i would really
like to see i think of course this is
all going to lead to secret wars
eventually maybe seven eight nine years
down the road where we're just going to
be seeing multiple different versions of
multiple different characters and i
think black widow is one that a lot of
people would really love to see so
hopefully things get worked out but in
the meantime let me know what you think
about this alternate ending for black
widow would you have preferred this or
do you like the one that we got and that
one was fine be sure to tell me in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you stay up to date on all things
happening in the mcu don't forget to
like the video if you enjoyed it and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof